[Music]  but it means it was Alex let go the main  who proposed in the Kargil march which  we can adhere of date at the end of the  proceedings and section next piece of  brass band music is popular worldwide  but brass bands and that's done more  than anything else I think to what are  the kögel of the men the southernmost  city in museums into the world and its  citizens I dedicate this mass as a  memento of many pleasant years spent  there in my voice with these words  inscribed on the sheet of music Alec  Lascaux brought Fame to this city  prepare to abandon contributed save us  to the musical disciplines throughout  the city it is packed last night we had  a concert of does the Siemens I suppose  you could say that's people  contributed still this day night to the  cultural richness and diversity of their  region without further ado I hereby  declare the sculpture of Alex let's go  open  [Music]  you  [Music]